Transcriber: Tarek Mamdouh
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
عُرف بالتعدد في مجالاته،
فقد كان رائدًا في الكثير من الأعمال؛
سواء على الصعيد العلمي أو الأدبي،
من الأبحاث إلى الاكتشافات حتى الجوائز
التي حصل عليها بالكتب والشعر.
شعاره في الحياة، كن أنت المفترق فلا يكونن
ما بعدك كما ما كان قبلك.
متحدثنا التالي ترك بصمته
بكل هذه الأعمال والميادين،
فمن غير المفاجئ أن يسطع نجمه اليوم
بحديثه الشيق بعنوان:
“بين الترجمة والتعريب والتغريب“.
رحبوا معنا بأحد أهم الدكاترة والباحثين
في مجال طب الأسنان على مستوى سوريا والعالم
الأستاذ الدكتور نبيل نادر قوشجي.
(تصفيق)
السلام عليكم، مرحبًا!
أنا نبيل قوشجي، نبيل بن نادر قوشجي.
سوف أحكي لكم اليوم عن ثلاث كلمات.
هناك مقولة تُنسب لابن حزم الأندلسي،
الرجل الذي ألف طوق الحمامة،
تقول المقولة:  “الحكم
على الشيء فرع من تصوره“.
ولكي نتصور شيئًا علينا أن ندخله
كخيال مجرد في أدمغتنا.
فإذا أردتُ أن أنقل هذه الصورة،
عليّ أن أحول الصورة
إلى أحرف منطوقة تعبرُ من دماغي
إلى لساني إلى آذانكم
لتعيد أدمغتكم ترجمتها،
فتتحول الصورة منقولة من دماغي إلى أدمغتكم.
هذا ما يفعله جهاز الهاتف
في جييه وجيبكِ وجيبكَ.
هذا ما يفعله تمامًا.
ينقل بيانات..
يحللها ويفكفكها ثم ينقلها
من مكان إلى مكان آخر.
إذًا علينا قبل أن نتحدث عن الترجمة
والتعريب وحتى التغريب،
علينا أن نعرف أن هناك أحرفًا
تحول الكلمات المجردة
إلى معانٍ أو إلى مصطلح.
ولأن الله خلقنا شعوبًا وقبائل،
فقد تعددت ألسنتنا،
ولأن الله خلقنا شعوبًا وقبائل لنتعارف،
فعلينا أن نجد آلية
لنقل المصطلح من لسان إلى لسان.
هذا ما تُعنى به الترجمة، فالترجمة تعني
إن أردنا تعريفًا مدرسيًا لها.
الترجمة تعني أن أنقل نصًا مكتوبًا ومقروءًا
أو منطوقًا ومسموعًا من لسان إلى لسان آخر.
على أية حال، قد يُنقل النص الواحد
بأكثر من طريقة عبر أكثر من تُّرجمان.
وهذا المثال الذي سأعطيكم مثال ساطع لذلك.
فقد كتب رجل اسمه عمر الخيام،
منذ مئات السنين،
نصًا اسماه رباعيات الخيام، كتبه بالفارسية
ونُقل إلى العربية أكثر من خمسين مرة،
لعل أشهر نَقلين له أو ترجمتين هما:
ترجمة أحمد صافي النجفي،
وترجمة أحمد رامي.
المعنيون بالأدب يقولون
إن ترجمة أحمد صافي النجفي
لرباعيات الخيام أكثر جزالة وعذوبة.
ومع ذلك فترجمة أحمد رامي أكثر شهرة.
إن أردنا أن نفسر الفكرة الأولى،
فنقول إن أحمد صافي النجفي نقل النص الفارسي
إلى اللغة العربية مباشرة،
فهو كان يتقن اللغتين.
بينما استعان أحمد رامي
بلغة وسيطة، بلسان وسيط،
فنقل من الفارسية
إلى الفرنسية التي نُقلت له،
ثم نقلها إلى العربية،
وقرأت بالأمس أنه نقلها من الإنجليزية.
على أية حال، اللغة الوسيطة أضعفت المعنى،
اللسان الوسيط أضعف المعنى،
ولكنه أكثر شهرة،
لأننا كلنا ندندن مع أم كلثوم:
“سمعتُ صوتًا هاتفًا في السحر
نادى من الغيب رفات البشر“.
نعم، باتت في أذاننا
لأننا سمعناها من أم كلثوم.
سأخرج عن الترجمة وأقول لكم،
لو جئنا بكلمة عمرها آلاف السنين:
عِلم الباثولوجيا (Pathology)،
وأردنا أن نحلل هذا المقطع الصوتي،
أقول لكم إنها كلمة إغريقية مكونة
من مقطعين “باثول” و“لوجي.
“باثول” تعني في الإغريقية
القديمة المغرقة بالقِدم: الألم،
ثم اصطُلح على أن تكون اسمًا للمرض،
لأن الإنسان في ذاك العصر لم يكن يخشى
من المرض سوى شيئًا واحدًا وهو.. الألم.
فاصطُلح على أن باثولوجي هي الألم والعلم.
ثم جيء بها لتُترجم،
وقبل أن يُؤتى بها إلى الترجمة،
نعرف أن الباثولوجي
هي بحر واسع جدًا جدًا جدًا،
وهي محيط متعدد الأبحر ومنه:
الأناتموباثولجي (Anatomopathology)،
فترجمت الباثولوجي إلى التشريح المرضي.
ولو قلت لأي عربي غير دارس للطب،
أو بعيد عن مجال الكليات الطبية،
لقلت له إنني مختص بالتشريح المرضي،
لجال في ذهنه أول ما يجول
أنني أتحدث عن تشريح الجثث،
وليس ذاك المعنى المطلوب.
ثم جاء تعريب، تعريب مبدع للمصطلح
فقيل الباثولوجي هي علم الأمراض.
فإذا قلت لكم إن الرجل الواقف أمامكم
يُعنى بعلم الأمراض وهو مختص به،
فستعلمون أن الأمراض وهي أمر واسع جدًا،
طيف واسع جدًا هي علم،
وهذا الرجل يتقن الخوض في عبابه.
فإذا جئنا إلى التغريب
وقلتُ لأحدهم إنني معني بالبثالوجيا،
فسيقف الرجل ويبتعد قليلًا،
وربما يقول، اللهم إن هذا منكرًا لا أرضاه.
لأنني لم أنقل له الصورة
من دماغي إلى دماغه،
أو ربما كان أكثر هلعًا فراحت عينيه
تدور في مقلتيه وهو يقول،
“دستور، لا نؤذيكم ولا تؤذونا“.
وإذا أردت أن أختم بعيدًا عن الألم
والأمراض فسوف أتحفكم بشيء،
هناك مثل إنجليزي يقول:
,Women powder their faces”
.“while men face powder
فإذا أردت أن أفكك الصورة فأقول:
تعني كلمة women بلغتنا نساء،
وتعني كلمة powder بلغتنا مسحوق بودرة.
وتعني their faces بلغتنا وجوههن.
وتعني while بلغتنا بينما،
أي فيما الظرفية،
وتعني men الرجال، وتعني face يواجه،
وتعني powder البارود.
فإذا أردت أن أصيغها مترجمة أقول:
“تضع النساء المساحيق على وجوههن،
فيما يواجه الرجال البارود“.
هذه ترجمة مكتملة الأركان،
لكن إن أردت أن أعرّبها فسأقول لكم:
“فيما تتجمل النساء،
يواجه الرجال الحديد والنار“.
وستعرفون كأي عربي أن الجملة الثانية
ألطف وأجزل وأشد وقعًا
في قلبك لأنها تلامس شغاف قلبك.
أما إن أردت أن تكون أديبًا
طبيبًا فستقول في عجالة:
هناك مرادف للمعنى عربي،
قبل المثل الإنجليزي
الذي عمره مئتي عام أو يزيد أو ينقص،
هناك شاعر عربي قبل ألف وخمسمئة عام،
قال بيت الشعر التالي:
“إن الكرامَ على الجياد مبيتُهم
فدعّي الرماح لأهلها، وتعطّري“.
مساؤكم،
ضوع عطور وعبق زهور وابتسامة حبور
تضفي على الأنفس أنفس الشعور.
السلام عليكم.
(تصفيق)